the oxford astrazeneca vaccine under
uncomfortable scrutiny
medicines regulators in the uk and the
eu have
judged that its benefits outweigh any
possible risks
but they haven't ruled out a causal link
between the vaccine
and rare blood clot conditions in a tiny
number of recipients
based on the current evidence the
benefits of the covid19 vaccine
astrazeneca against covid19
and its associated risks hospitalization
and death continues to outweigh the
risks
for the vast majority of people
our review has reinforced that the risk
of this rare suspected side effect
remains extremely small in amsterdam the
european medicines agency said there was
insufficient data to isolate risk
factors like age and gender
and that blood clotting should be listed
as a possible side effect of the jab
this case also shows us that our
pharmacovigilance system is working
these very rare unusual events have been
picked up
identified analyzed and have allowed us
to come to science-based recommendations
to allow the safe and effective use of
this vaccine
investigations into the astrazeneca
vaccine were triggered after rare cases
of blood clotting in the uk and europe
out of 20 million doses of the vaccine
given in britain
79 cases of clotting were reported with
19
deaths resulting in a minute percentage
chance of complications
affecting four in every million people
vaccinated
the uk regulator went a step further
than its european counterpart
announcing that adults under 30 could be
offered an
alternative vaccine if one is available
at the time
and if they're currently healthy and not
at higher risk from covert 19.
in reaching their conclusions the
regulators have had to weigh up the
risks
for older people and those at greater
danger from covid19 well
the minute risk attached to the vaccine
is one worth taking
but for fit healthy younger people less
vulnerable to the virus
those odds are more finely balanced so
in these age groups the uk
regulator is proceeding with more
caution
it's not a clean slate for the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
already blighted by political disputes
and manufacturing delays question marks
over possible side effects could
further dent its credibility even if the
regulator's verdict is that it's broadly
safe joe nahul al jazeera london